a tiniest fraction 400 Americans I've
given half the money in this election
cycle so far that's not American
democracy that's banana republic modest
but we have no right we white Americans
who came to this country without a visa
who came to this country without the
permission of the Native Americans who
were here in this country we have no
right to exclude others from this
country in the way that we have in the
past 50 years I think the black lives
matter movement is the most important
political movement to remind America
about how it has betrayed its
fundamental commitment of course when
America was born we had betrayed that
commitment through slavery
I think I might be the most liberal drug
decriminalization person in this
campaign I think we've wasted an
extraordinary amount of money and human
lives in this ridiculous war on drugs a
war which has not only destroyed whole
communities in the United States but
destroyed whole countries in South
America and across the world I think
Donald Trump has done the best of things
and the worst of things the best of
things is in the Republican Party he
pulled back the curtain on the way money
corrupts the system standing on debate
stage calling out every one of those
candidates for president emphasizing the
way all of them were dependent on large
donors to fund their campaigns because
it brought all of us to recognize in a
cross partisan way the corrupting
influence of money in politics bernie is
identifying all the amazing things that
we as Americans have to do and most of
the things he's talking about I
completely agree with but he is not
given a plan for house he can if he's
going to fix this corrupted system he is
not he has not committed himself to
fixing this corrupted system first he's
identified the problems of corruption
he's pointed to the right answers but
checking off a box is not a plan and
what I've said is we have to commit
ourselves to fixing this democracy first
if any of these amazing ideas that he's
talking about her even possible
if we take on student debt we take on
the most powerful political interest in
America today those banks who defend
this system where they have guaranteed
loans yet charged incredibly high
interest rates to the borrowers are
going to fight this reform with every
ounce of energy they've got and so if
we're going to have a chance to win we
have to change the system where they
have so much power